I know you know reality shows don't get
the respect that I believe they deserve
why do you think people sign up to watch
you I think because I am so open my
smartest business decision has been
going for it and not be like having no
fear when you do take time for yourself
that's when like the magic happens and
these ideas come hello believe nation
it's Evan my one word is believe and I
believe in people more than they believe
in themselves and my sincere hope is
that if you see in yourself what I see
in you you'll be able to change the
planet so to help you on your journey
today we're going to learn from
entrepreneur actress and TV personality
Kim Kardashian and my take on our top
ten rules of success rule number two is
my personal favorite and I'd love to
know which one you guys like to buy also
as you're watching if you hear something
that really resonates with you please
leave it down in the comments below I
put quotes around it so other people can
be inspired by it as well and if you
leave it within the first couple hours
of this video going live you have a
chance to win one of two daily prizes
do you think that people underestimate
you underestimate your how much you work
on this stuff underestimate your
intelligence and my question is is that
something you push back on or something
you leverage definitely something that
doesn't bother me
um when someone underestimates me I love
to get to know them and have them have
one conversation with me to just
understand that it's I mean I think the
easiest question to ask is what does she
do what is your talent you know and I
jerking li said actually to my husband
the other day I said you know what how
low my next answer should be like
sarcastically how lucky am i if I don't
sing and I don't dance what I'm still
doing what I'm doing how easy is my job
I'll have to do any of that I don't have
to be on stage like you working you know
so hard but we're still driving the same
car we're still living the same life you
know so like you mean you know it was
that easy but you know I think it's just
like the easiest thing to ask for anyone
to really assume that it's not a
full-time job to have to sit and create
things and come up with every single
blog post and I do you know three a day
and having to you know working on apps
it's to me it would be the same thing as
people saying like anything blogging
like what do you do you're sitting at
home and your apartment and you're just
on the computer like that I think people
are do farming or don't say that I know
and I respect it so much you know and
they say that you know about the
modeling world well they just sit there
looking pretty it is a full-time job for
you know models like you know my sister
even you know Kendall it's I I don't
mind getting underestimated but I feel I
feel for people that I understand how it
could bother them if they were put in
the same situation even filming a
reality show it's a full-time job I mean
I think that I know you know reality
shows don't get the
facts that I believe they deserve and
that's why I love being on one for so
long and I will you know always fight to
you know be on as long as possible
because I love to show and prove but my
personality is just if you underestimate
me I would love to have a conversation
with you I would love to I just like to
prove people wrong why do you think
people sign up to watch you I think
because I am so open you know I think
now you do these yourself you said this
you absolutely you're a team a page on
every I didn't see any chasing you
around ya know I don't have a team I
love to if it's the whole connection is
me with other people I don't want
someone else it makes no sense to have
that think about that you were know as
well when I said there were people that
I have that you don't have anybody doing
any analytical media no it's that
doesn't make sense what have you found
in these new platforms and tools and you
articulated how each one is different
how you see each one meeting of certain
purpose what do you found has worked and
what have you found hasn't worked from
all of that experience I think that
doing anything and everything and I'm
guilty of that before how people
probably won't believe you and you
probably don't even really grasp what
you like now if I'm going to promote
something I have to use it I have to
like it I have to be active with it I
want to know the partners I want to know
who owns the company I want to know so
much about it and I love to be loyal to
that company and just do what's
authentic to me so but I tried so many
things in the past and I think through
all of that experience you just learn
what you like and what you love and but
I think the key on social media is just
being authentic you have to have the
work ethic if you don't have that
you don't want to work 24/7 then it's
not really going to go to you know work
for you but I also think that you just
have to be super authentic no matter
what you do no matter what business
you're in social media definitely helps
to bring that vision to life and to
share that with the world and to be
accessible to everyone but you really do
have to do the work and be authentic
about it my smartest business decision
has been going for it and not the like
having no fear and just even if they
fails and even if it hasn't turned out
the way that I wanted to I've learned so
much from it so my advice would be go
for it everything is about learning
experience is there something like a
specific example you can think of that
maybe wasn't this one institution or
something that you did that you're like
oh okay except it's so much differently
back in the day I used to just be
involved with so much yeah whether it
was like tanning or shoes you know I
start on your name on your dad oh yeah
which I mean I loved the process of it
all but you know being a cupcake you
know sponsor to a cupcake store I mean
like everything but put it throwing
myself into everything taught me
everything I know now so I wouldn't take
any of it back I pride myself in my work
ethic and I work really hard so I think
that you know I think that sometimes
when people hear that I might have
gotten success off of a reality show
right they take that as a negative so I
think that I you know we're filming our
10th season right now and we've had I
think nine seasons have spin-offs and so
our show and then we have more episodes
and I Love Lucy I mean we have so many
amazing milestones that people don't
really stop and think about people don't
understand when you are even though it
is reality we wait I wake up every
single day at 6 a.m. and you know go to
the gym and you know get my daughter up
feed my baby
get ready film all day sometimes don't
finish until you know 8 or 9 P
and that's every single day six days a
week for five months straight when we
weren't filming and so that in itself is
a full-time job mixed in with you know
every other project that we're working
on and I just unfortunately I just don't
think reality TV gets the respect that
it deserves what did you imagine what
did you want to be when you grew up when
I was about 13 years old I looked at my
best friends and the show the real world
had just come out and so I said to her
oh my gosh that's what I want to do I
want to be on a reality show well you
have to be my manager and she looked at
me and said well I said we both have to
audition for the real world let's make a
tape when we're 18 we'll send it in to
the producers and we have to do this
show called the real world she was like
you can do it I'm not a chance for me
I'll be your manager and you you know
we'll make a tape for you so it's just
like such a full-circle moment because
she's a manager now she's in the
management business and my show is
produced by the people that did the real
world
I just thought our family life has
always been interesting it's never a
dull moment everyone that came into our
life said oh my gosh I can't believe you
guys aren't on TV I can't believe your
family isn't a sitcom or something since
you know reality TV wasn't so popular
then so it's just I mean I did have a
clothing store which I still have today
- that you know was fashion when I was
in high school I worked at a clothing
store so if that didn't pan out if the
real world didn't pan out then fashion
is really what I wanted to get into and
I you know I worked it you know that the
clothing store and my sisters and I
opened one up and so I thought that's
really where I was going to be and
that's what I was going to be doing I
know I think that my mom and my
grandmother have always been really good
role models my mom is very strong I
think she's had to deal with a lot in
her life
and she always puts on a brave face and
always wants everyone to feel
comfortable and confident and I really
admire that in her how do you find time
to brainstorm where you can just shut
everything out and take a pause and say
okay maybe I would re-examine this well
I think when you I do take time for
myself and I think that's very important
and even going to Japan and seeing so
many amazing things I got so many great
ideas and when you do take time for
yourself that's when like the magic
happens and these ideas come and I think
no matter who you are what you do if you
don't take time for yourself you can
never rejuvenate and you can never get
back that creative spark so I do take
time off and I do get a lot of ideas
from my travels and just being around
people that give me ideas and inspire me
so I think that is really important and
I'll wake up in the middle of the night
sometimes with these ideas and I'll just
send it to my team and hopefully not
wake them all up in the middle of the
night is in business I love looking at
my peers and seeing that you know young
successful women like Jessica Alba you
know I suppose to her this morning and
we were just you know picking each
other's brains on something like I love
her dedication and she's always been
someone that I've looked up to
business-wise she's just a really smart
girl I call I like to surround myself
with people that I could always call for
advice you know my best friend is now in
the management business has now gone
into like product placement business and
started a company on her own and it's
been fascinating to see her build her
brand in her business one of my other
best friends two of them were in
publicity for a long time so I like to
pick their brains on you know perception
of things and you know I just I love to
surround myself with people that I can
call and get good advice from all the
time I think it
important she had a terrible time she
came into Paris Fashion Week and she
ended up being tied up to furniture with
a gun pointed at her head in her luxury
apartments hey I want to talk to you
about the Paris sensitive because I know
you get an episode on the show about it
and I haven't spoken to you since then
I've had your family members on but I
think that I don't know that everybody
understands how horrific that experience
must have been for you yeah I mean I
know this sounds crazy but I know that
was meant to happen to me and I don't
want to start crying by like I feel like
that was so meant to happen to me like
I'm such a different person and like I
don't want to start crying anymore but
um yeah I think you can cry it was it
was meant to happen to me like the
things I really feel like things happen
in your life to teach you things and
this was like I'm yep like I I was you
know it was probably no secret you see
it on the show and it's being flashy
like I was definitely materialistic
before and not that there's anything bad
with having things and working hard to
get those things and I'm really proud of
you know everyone around me bit
successful but like I'm so happy that my
kids get this me and that this is who
I'm raising my kids because I just don't
care about that stuff anymore really
I mean you know like I said everyone
gets so excited yeah you know when they
get things or every you know of course
when you get engaged you're going to
show off your ring you know people if
they get a new car don't care what kind
is you get so proud you get so happy and
you show that off on social media but
it's just it's it's just it's not worth
it like I don't care about that stuff I
don't care to show off like the way that
I used to even though there's nothing
truly like it's okay if you're proud of
that you know when you work so hard and
you get something it's just not who I am
anymore so you you were in because you
were showing these diamonds because you
were in Paris you showed off what you
had yeah and you think that that
attracted those guys and they said she
has all this in her apartment and I just
I'm trying to understand so because I
can't imagine being you were alone yeah
and you're it's what time is it was
about almost like 2:30 in the morning
but what was crazy is meeting with my
attorneys and knowing the information
that I know now they had been following
me for two years and they have been
hearing interviews that I did getting
excited about this jewelry or this
jewelry and saying that it's you know
real and it's not to say that I'll never
wear jewelry again or anything like that
I truly don't know if I'd ever feel
comfortable I truly don't know if I'd
ever wear real jewelry again I you know
just my whole life has changed as far as
like how I travel and what you know
security I never thought that I needed
security staying outside my door even
though I had a lot of jewelry and and if
you think about it yeah I should have
had a security guard outside my door
24/7 when I'm traveling and I didn't now
I have several you know just for me to
be able to sleep at night but how did
they get how did they get in the door
was locked right yes the door was locked
I didn't answer the door they held a gun
up to the concierge that was downstairs
and said let us up to where's the
robbers wife and that air them not know
your name
and yeah alright so lettuce oh yeah they
let them up to the room and he open the
door for them handcuffs but open the
door not to call the police right away
once or did they probably held on to him
so he wouldn't call the police
they had like handcuffed him and tied
him up in the stairwell so he couldn't
so when they left I were you awake or
were you asleep I was just about to fall
asleep but I was awake so so you heard
people in there I heard people running
up the stairs and I thought it was my
sister and my friend drunk coming home
and I was calling out for them like I
was debated going out not going out
going like all night and then finally
I'm like you know I'm just going to stay
in and pack and my one of my high school
friends who's a stylist that came with
us on that trip she was downstairs in a
bedroom and they didn't know that she
was there with us so she heard what was
going on and she heard me screaming and
so she called my sister and my security
but okay so but let's get there there
with you yeah they have a gun mm-hmm are
you hysterically crying are you like
what how do you react in a situation
like that well automatically might you
know your stomach drops it's a feeling
you can't even explain and you like I
knew that was it for me like I don't
really die 100% 100% I said a prayer and
like I know I'm going to heaven I hope
my kids are okay my husband I wanna cry
everything refresh but you know you you
it just happened really fast it was a
good like you know seven or eight
minutes of like torture but when I look
back and I analyze it I'm like okay they
weren't really a great like it could
have been way worse so I don't want to
sound you know like I'm not grateful
like they think I'm out I'm home I'm
safe yeah I'm such a better person I'm
it's okay like
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because Christopher
Tumlin asked me to if there's someone
you like better profile in their future
top ten please check out the link down
in the description below and you can
cast your vote on who we should do next
I also want to give a quick shout out to
2000 books thank you so much for picking
up a copy of my book your one word and
doing that fun interview together on
your YouTube channel I really really
really appreciate the support and I'm so
glad that you enjoyed the read today we
have Evan Carmichael my mentor and we're
talking about is awesome book your one
word thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love I'll see you soon
and I've always just been open I've
always been super open with my life and
that's just who I am and it worked out
because that's how my family is too so
we can be really candid and it's kind of
the irony because my husband is
completely the opposite and you know he
doesn't know yet we know gran about
everybody's all over Instagram now would
you yeah closing when you appeared on
the cover of Forbes a year ago you
tweeted not bad for a girl with no
talent which is quite an irony giving
the obvious talents you have what do you
say to those who downplay or dismiss
your successor you just have the feeling
that success is the best revenge you
able to be like the duck just let it
roll off the back I do let it roll off
my back I do feel like success is the
best revenge
absolutely to say that I'm not human for
people to always say crazy mean things I
mean it definitely does get to me but I
think that I've with the support of my
family we've always kind of come through
on the other side but to write that I
remember I was thinking do I why I don't
want to be boastful and say I'm on the
cover of Forbes this is you know so
amazing which you do want to say but of
course people will be say something
negative about that so I thought it was
funny just the little hashtags for
people that might question how I got
here or what talent I have how's like
I'm on the cover of Forbes so I must be
doing something right I love sharing but
I do think there are limits to it and I
think you have to have boundaries
and I don't have any you wouldn't go to
your bounce I do I it took me a while to
get to share things with my daughter and
I was really hesitant about that for a
while and I still don't post all the
things that we do want a daily basis
where I see some of my friends their
instagrams are all of their you know
their children and so I am you know
protective over that I am protective
over my relationship sometimes with over
sharing about that because
I've made mistakes and I think over
shared in the path yes yes which I think
sometimes could be just it didn't work
out for me that way okay I felt money
Prudential or gaia sharing that you
going to take back oh yeah I'm sure I'd
have to look at some things I mean even
some I love hair and makeup in the glam
process and I share a lot about that and
tips and tricks and I'm fascinated by
the beauty blogger space and YouTube and
how so many different beauty bloggers
have you know risen to fame just off of
their tutorials I look at them I we do
fun tutorials all the time me and my
makeup artists and and hairstylist
so there's probably some glam moments
where I thought what was I thinking and
why am i wearing that color lipstick and
why did I post that boundaries are
definitely important social media is
amazing and it's fun and it's great but
it cannot you know you do have to have
boundaries just like anything else you
know you can't watch too much TV you
can't eat too much candy I mean whatever
it is you just have to set boundaries
and I think there are certain guidelines
with that of whether it's no phones at
the table while you're eating dinner or
you know meals and make that a rule in
the household I mean I definitely will
have rules for sure